so today topic use open file middle of
the game it's one of the important
strategy a typical ideas and I showed
this position for you so who can tell me
that is open file
you mean app or which one open file
there is open file who can tell me okay
so very important to see it if it's
white fonts or black bones if a black
bones doesn't matter because open file
you can attack on open file if there is
palm or weeks crown if it's white bone
of course deep it won't block the Queen
yeah and you cannot attack on D file so
we can say that being sent to adventure
and be part is open yes till this time
scroll but we can attack the pawn on b7
right the file is closed because pawn on
d3 block the Queen right do you
understand this and H file is open from
H free scroll to h7 because we can
attack the phone on h7 and then a few
chicken on the shade if for example rook
on h1 of course we cannot attack because
phone on H to block our hope they
understand this okay good
yeah so I want to show you one game a
very interesting game and this game
plays to play to grandmaster just one
week ago in the wakens a so it was round
number nine and four vide was very good
master was a low rating 2706 and for
black Navarro David was rating twenty
seven thirty and it's very interesting
game so let's look at E 4 E 5 Knight f3
knight c6 this should be 5 Knight of 6
who knows the name of opening it calls
but in defense okay you cannot so deep
free Bishop c5 Bishop takes c6 d take C
success story Knight bTW to Castle
kingside
and that appears is that possible Knight
takes e5 to make this move yes Queen d4
right now yeah so after Queen D for its
double attack on the Knight f5 Knight e5
and upon F - yeah and a for example
Castle kingside
we will take the knight if neither mo we
will take the pawn or left - so Knight
takes e5 as a Banda what's fun about a
debit of course didn't play the smooth
he played Knight d4 Knight f d7 Queen e2
and the rook e8 so rook e8 it's a
typical idea of middle game we have pawn
on e5 and e4 right now this one block of
a look right but in the future it can be
dangerous for white because white has
Queen only 2 and kin only one okay so we
put a rock on the same farm there is
Queen and King Bishop d2 we should
Bishop d6 so why black decided to make
the small what do you think what was the
main idea of the smoke okay you have a
good idea but Knight b6 is not very well
known but black want to make movies the
night with the idea to open be shot
first of all to develop the bishop yes
so Bishop this that protect the pawn on
e5 also that can push the five in the
future okay so H form what do you think
about this move is it good more or no
okay what is the idea of the small okay
wait around yeah so h4 it's a typical
idea of middle game because if you want
to attack on the Kin side and push the
pawns yes so it's good and open H file
or G file in the future C 5 H 5 now what
black should play
what is the main idea for white in this
position after h5h serves was idea why
yh6
yes yes of course very well so but pawn
after h6 is weak and white can use it in
the future
so Castle queenside Knight a fight was
correct mu for black was the idea to
play Knight is six and to stop g5 in the
future but Nevada decided to play Knight
b8 so room dg1 in this position why why
decided to make the snow were different
okay so why I'd want to improve all
pieces right and to pull g4 g5 to open G
file right okay
96 now what is the best move for white
g4 right f6
what why should play in this position
okay it's interesting idea after f6g
subscribes week and night can use it but
wine has better idiom Bishop takes h6
doesn't work because G take statistics
did you see this game okay so G PI
sometimes you can play slowly you can
improve your pieces focus on ones cloud
for example like in this position on G
file this idea to open this file do you
file yeah but sometimes you can
sacrifices pieces this idea to open file
if your pieces of course are ready to
attack
so after G fine alright first black to
open G file so f takes night eggs and
you can ask me then I can play slowly
then I can calculate some combinations
yes it's a question first of course
first of all of course you should
improve your pieces and all the pieces
should be ready for attack you should
focus on one square or in some file and
then you can think about some tactical
ideas how you can sacrifice at the bone
or some piece and you will have
compensation ok
also you will have advantage in space
yes and then you push your pawns
you can cut black pieces to the
background and it will be good for you
you will have strong attack so Knight d4
in this position what do I should play
tell me yes
blog won't take the Queen only two so
what do I should play okay you have mu
queen Ivana what else
Queenie Freire what else
now we will discuss late about all these
moves okay 21s little parcel right and
also maybe a freestyle this week after
Queen Yvonne so in the future night a
free can be dangerous right also Queen
only II one has no job you should win
after attack the King right and only one
it's too passive okay what about Queen
III you like it okay who doesn't like
yes after Queen III you block your
bishop and it's not good what will you
do after H take g5 f queen Eric H tags
if I take this the rook
yeah if for example Queen III M H takes
a look take G fires but the bishop on d2
has no job and the main idea of night
eggs if I'm also after H take g5 take
this the bishop and I take the Queen
with the temple so you should play
quickly you sacrifice of the pieces you
cannot improve your pieces you have no
time right so if Queen III and Queen e1
are not good moves
what do I should play
21 yeah Queen d1 okay H like g5 now what
on h6 yes it's better take four so for
Bishop to g5 and in the future push h6
so if Bishop is 7 what we will play here
we Bishop h6 Bishop f6 I understand
bishop absent yes bishop take g7 is
interesting we should take JSON h6 yes
motive Knight is 6
in each pie what else Knight takes d5 so
which moves better Knight takes e5 image
file image five is interesting
maybe rookie 7
a dog takes so much more in the shake
50 Nissan so Luke takes juice on you and
should be winning for white yeah okay so
how black and defend became better
what the deuce of g5 here we bacon be
wanna know
okay
stoking each fire yeah you should
improve your clean
I love Jade
okay it's interesting
if for example Kane f6
how about Knight to f3
and I take my tics okay yeah what's
wrong it's really dangerous
so maybe I should play night II 6 to
protect my vision through this scrum
right because I cannot stop looking free
when I take G pipe yeah ok so nighty 6
in between g6 was idea to exchange the
pieces
in which position
if Quinn takes
so it's interesting because why it still
has some compensation right but it's a
little difficult for white to improve a
check here and black has time to defend
the King right okay let's go back to the
game so Bishop h6 was the interesting
move but we decided to move you should
if we here was the same idea to push h6
but don't give the bishop further home
so same idea to open each file and g5
yes what was the phone so and of course
don't trade the pieces Bishop f6 now
what
H of course all pieces are ready to
attack and you need to push h6 okay what
do you think about G final but more why
let's do it for the King right okay it's
interesting more clean edge fine but
what will we do after g4 can they check
how we can improve your idea Queen h5
okay let's analyze
and every yeah
it should be six can I change
you need your Bishop on a dream yeah
we cannot exchange this bishop
so how we can open G file this would
take Japan this would take G fine after
that
so now your idea F for
write F for Bishop cannot take yes if it
takes us for now KH fine
you see how it's beautiful yeah and it's
when in position for white of course no
like didn't play G file but the line is
interesting that's why I show you
rookie 7 black plate so what do I should
play take the pawn look take g7 finish
why what is the main idea of MOOC in
each file okay
so the main idea of MOOC lineage file
double the pieces on each file right to
play finish 7oq initiate in the future
to use seventh or eighth rank okay
Bishop e6 Bishop h6 no it's white useful
it's good for the idea to attack the
Rope yes
dry out the defender and trade the rooks
open G file after that you can attack
the King
okay Bishop up seven okay we should take
g7 Bishop h5 Bishop f6 for the work
should play a check yes black should
move is the king
so - which file H file or a pipe cleaner
faith okay Bishop the eight right 92
what what a leader here
possible kindy - and but I decided to
play kimby one night big G one again it
came Vito what so that should take the
right yeah
what do i do Oakley take the bishop take
the room now what
possible but this night on g1 is weak so
you can try to play something like
kidney fee with the idea of king of 795
of course Luke g5 something like this
yeah rook takes d5 Knight X if I win in
position for white so it's possible to
play kindy - but why decided to play can
be 191 so what will you do
no white oh I take the bishop on h5 do
you mean yes it's better take the pawn
on c7 and the for example rook c8 what
will you do
check yeah so in this position black
design because it's double attack on the
bishop h5 Nyjah Vanya and only 5 is weak
so why don't one the game ok I hope so
you can use it in a video game because
it's very important
of course topic open file night